imprévisible jacques lafleur le pilier
du rpr locales porte drapeau de la lutte
anti indépendantistes
depuis plusieurs mois ils demandaient
avec force la dissolution du fln ks
aujourd'hui il accepte de rencontrer ses
adversaires jean marie tjibaou voire de
négocier avec lui à certaines conditions
quand il aura retrouvé cette liberté
d'appartenir à un parti qui donne son
opinion mais qui ne veut rien imposer
par la violence tous les espoirs sont
permis en quelques semaines deux
événements ont sans doute pesé dans la
réflexion du député la fleur mais aussi
de tous les esprits en nouvelle
calédonie deux événements qui ont agit
en quelque sorte comme des électrochocs
la tragique affaire d'ouvéa la
réélection de françois mitterrand à la
présidence de la république
lorsque la mission nommée par le premier
ministre arrive à nouméa c'est pour
entendre écouter renoué comme on l'a dit
souvent les fils du dialogue
un objectif aujourd'hui partiellement
accomplie de la côte est à la côte ouest
partis politiques syndicats hommes
d'église partenaires économiques
tous ont été reçus chacun des six
envoyés spéciaux a enregistré des
dizaines de témoignages pour le préfet
christian blanc il doit à présent
remettre un rapport à michel rocard
il ne s'agit pas pour lui d'élaborer un
nouveau statut cela c'est la tâche du
gouvernement
pourtant jacques lafleur lui y pense à
ce futur statut dans une interview
accordée au figaro
il déclare ne pas être favorable à une
partition du territoire
mais dit il un mauvais accord vaut mieux
qu'une bonne guerre civile ce n'est pas
sans surprise que ses propos ont été
enregistrés à nouméa
surprise au sein du propre parti de
jacques lafleur
surprise aussi des indépendantistes
là je pense que le temps est est
intéressant il est sûr que nous avons
dans cette période et ce taux depuis 86
maintenant qu'est ce qu'il y a dans le
panier des sacrifices et d'efforts
session je ne sais pas donc de toutes
façons on attend aussi pouvoir la
période semble donc propice à une
rencontre des différents partenaires
concernés par l'avenir de la nouvelle
calédonie est pour l'instant sur cet
avenir
le gouvernement affirme avoir aucune
idée préconçue